no and welcome to this video playing I'm
a cord from Austria at least it's an
Austrian flag and so what the heck is
that that's a very rare opening hmm yeah
I'm just developing normally should be
five Bishop chatham but take on is six
isn't that better for white maybe it's
not much but okay otherwise it doesn't
make any sense but what happens here oh
it just takes it with a pawn okay hmm
yeah do I take now or not I mean
probably it's better to put the bishop
here keep an eye on you six
Jem those pawns don't look brilliant but
other than that black is ok here
development is decent yeah I guess I'll
just castle short necks and try things
like we never to Bishop down don't
really see the idea 97 maybe ok I'm
gasoline you
so can we have to maybe trying to
provoke a weakness and dads it's
definitely possible don't like my knight
on c3 and this is really not a good
piece 9 p-5 and then there's just a six
that doesn't really eat too much ok I'm
going to regroup that night well ok if
it goes to f4
I have a very very good structure him
very sound solid structure and e5 e6 our
weaknesses so it's just a question of
how much better it is for white maybe it
is not much i'm totally not sure if them
and i'm having something substantial
here
yeah it's all so clear to make some
substantial progress with YTM I can
detect those pawns but like it's
defending them quite um quite easily so
what about trading some stuff Mia this
is an idea just trade this Bishop
okay so i can go to a g4 now or to d3
both continuations make some sense what
just III I put this back and maybe this
one go to the six anyway and now i would
also like to trade queens this would be
helpful hmm Jim it's not so easy easy
though and it's not clear my bishop is
doing much maybe I should make sure that
he actually trades
okay make sure if I should go to the 3m
home my bishop on g5 is also not great
ok let's go down can I can step back now
I should try to trade Queen Sam it's not
easy though and they need to be 3m a tag
is sex
so we tried to sacrifice on e4 not sure
one queen bee three that time warning
would actually work okay let's gain some
space now it shouldn't work at least not
objectively speaking
yeah maybe he can still do that king of
2 and check efore with 50 seconds on the
clock this is not so easy to play for me
you
yep of course check
and this is not at all easy with this
time situation
check check check
hmm I don't know it no idea i don't
think that time this is really good what
like is doing but check I thought yet he
had good play for the piece but i'm not
sure what this stuff him know where
coordination is pretty good check rah
c4i damn it this is just damn Jack I
know he has a draw check check check
check check game drawn ah what the heck
yeah i mean this this didn't it should
be just good for white Queens you to us
is a bit better though and then like if
I problem yeah anyway it was a game
where after the opening I was always a
bit better but it's difficult to do
something with it um those pawns are
clearly a weakness but you don't have a
clear way of attacking them so I think
this must be basically all right also i
think the trades were good I'm basically
happy with how I played this up up to
here roughly can provoke that one yeah
and from from here you have to ride out
this position and try to make something
out of it because blacks counter play
now it's down to nothing
you just have to be very gas circumspect
and don't allow stuff probably I
shouldn't have allowed Knight takes e4
from a practical point of view and play
something else him the engine wants to
play be three I mean now the Sham what
better version check at here Y twins
maybe this is better the engine is on
roughly plus one which which seems high
I mean it's clear that White's better
but one pawn sounds like a lot okay and
now he check played this which was a i
think a good practical decision I was
expecting queen of five years and said
didn't didn't really think was so great
ya know why does Sam is winning again
according to the computer well it's not
easy to play so chan check i was a jolly
happy giving giving back all those
because a number coordination is good
again and check this yeah can probably
be shiny for here yeah and the crew g
twister better interestingly enough
which is probably this is threatening
bishop 65 okay and it's very strong
actually Bishop takes the five is a big
threat Black has to do something like
this and return the pawn and this is
very nice for a while yeah I probably I
spend a little bit too much time in the
position like that where you don't have
much more than just trade stuff and hope
to do to something in the ending
okay anyway thanks for watching